Speaker 1: There is something super interesting
going on in South Carolina where failed former
President Donald Trump is really struggling
to find state lawmakers willing to show up
at this stupid rally event he has planned for
this weekend and support him on stage. Now,
let me kind of remind you what's going on.
Trump's running for president again in 2024.
He announced relatively early. He basically hasn't
left his house since the announcement in November,
but now he is starting events. One such event is
in South Carolina this weekend. Our correspondent
Luke Beasley is going to be there. He will be
interviewing people. Should be pretty interesting
content that we will have for you as a result.
Now, Trump doesn't seem to be struggling to
get federal level lawmakers who represent South
Carolina to go and stand with him at the rally.
But the state lawmakers are hilariously not
super thrilled about participating. There
is a Rolling Stone article so sad. Trump's South
Carolina rally getting little support from state
lawmakers despite making numerous pleading
phone calls. The former president's team is
hitting a wall in the state, writes Peter Wade
for Rolling Stone. The Washington Post reports
that Trump's team has been making fleeting phone
calls to potential supporters across the state,
but many are responding with less than enthusiasm
because South Carolina lawmakers are not yet ready
to commit to a candidate, especially when two of
the state's Republicans are eyeing presidential
runs themselves. That's South Carolina. Former
South Carolina Governor Nikki Haley and current
South Carolina Senator Tim Scott. The article
also mentions Lindsey Graham and Henry McMaster
are expected to show up and show support.
This is really, really interesting because
if you look at polling in South Carolina, you
find that the majority of South Carolina's
residents disapprove of Trump. And to a certain
degree, it seems as though the state politicians,
people in the state House, state Senate are either
on the same page in their disapproval for Trump or
are kind of reading the tea leaves and saying,
well, I don't know that I want to get ahead of
myself and to support Trump and be publicly seen
and tied to Trump when many of my constituents
don't seem to be big fans. We don't even know
if Trump will be the nominee. We don't know what
things will look like come next year. And so you
end up with this situation where only five of the
state's Republican senators and representatives
are publicly supporting Trump. Some, like Jeff
Duncan, are pushing back against his policies
and have been critical of Trump's trade policy,
for example, or have said Trump hasn't been doing
the right things to make the immigration system
more fair or whatever the case may be. And then
some state reps from South Carolina have gone
even further than simply not voicing support.
You've got, for example, like Nancy Mace, who
is trying to pass legislation that undermines some
of Trump's policy ideas, like she wants to protect
so-called Dreamers from deportation, whereas
Trump was open to deporting Dreamers. So this
is potentially going to be a problem for Trump as
this campaign tries to get going. There have been
advisers to Trump just blanketing South Carolina,
trying to find people to come and support him. And
the important thing to remember and we learned
this from the Democratic primary. Just because a
candidate can have a rally with a few thousand
people. It doesn't necessarily mean that they
are well-liked statewide. And, you know, one of
the things we experienced during the Democratic
primary was that if you base your estimates of
support for Bernie Sanders based on Twitter and
Reddit and I was one of his supporters, you had
a much inflated sense of Bernie support within
the Democratic Party. And then when voting
actually started taking place, you got a
very different sense. And we know ultimately how
that went down. That all being said, the polls,
as we reviewed yesterday, are still looking pretty
good for Trump in the Republican primary. There
was a period there in early December where
Ron DeSantis was really doing quite well in
the polling. But it does appear, at least right
now, that Donald Trump has a commanding lead in
just about every Republican primary poll of
substance. That being said, nobody else has
announced Trump is being put up in polls against
people who aren't even officially running yet.
And that could mean something quite different
once we get more announcements. So we're going
to follow it. I will not be covering the rally
this weekend. I'm actually going to be away,
but Luke Beazley's going to be there and
then we'll have clips for when I am back